Ma dici che sono tanto mafioso siciliano
Secondo me Mamma mia Bravo Fammi un
intro la Sicilia €30 da Marlù questo è
oro finto va bene
Siamo su in realtà non sappiamo bene
cosa registrare quindi penso faremo un
po' di giochini di quelli che facevo ai
tempi quindi jogasser higher fritto
misto di web i giochini sono qua a casa
di Gian Perché a casa mia stanno
pitturando i muri e non possono registra
re Allora Spagna contro the Joe rogan
Experience Mamma mia io si guarda stavo
cercando una battuta ma con qua eh Ovvio
Ovvio
ha letteralmente aperto delle acque Sì
se qualcuno non lo cerca perché ha
aperto Allora Cosa si deve fare per
intrattenere sul web Oggi c'è uno che
apre le acque a così pochi click non ci
credo Deutsche Bank la famosissima banca
dove nessuno di noi ha soldi Esatto vai
Però di più 3 milioni 3 milioni non è
male Sic
Jackson Five senza Michael Jackson
[Musica]
è razzismo l'hanno messo proprio vicino
è una strana composizione non si capisce
Certo
Secondo me almeno 300.000 400.000 Non
male razzismo con il fabbro dipende
perché solo se giochi a World Warcraft
sta ricerca l'avevi pensata anche senza
in realtà made in due eh quindi quei
giocatori hanno giocato un sacco ma ma
meno del razzismo ragazzi assolutamente
meno Vabbè siamo a 9 9 e tantissimi è
tanto
Beh ehm
Ancelotti Guarda che guarda che mi sa
che se non sbaglio
ha allenato anche Ancelotti
tipo Leicester davvero
ci sta riprendendo non ci credo mi
ricordavo che nulla ne lavano italiano
Leicester Scusate te lo giuro ci sei
andato ricerche
no bro Ma che cazzo tutto Raga non lo so
hanno River Che cazzo è boh meno che ci
andate anche bene Comunque il celebre
presente e quella cosa che se tu giochi
tanto a un gioco poi non smetti di
giocare a quel gioco e ricominci sei più
forte sempre sempre sempre sempre sempre
sempre tu l'hai notato Perché Hai votato
video di giochi come ho giocato dopo un
po' e quindi hai visto
Sailor Swift Minecraft
1.0 Anche se comunque KFC le sue 8
milioni di views Eh ce l'avrai vegano
questa immagine comunque
5 Comunque ovviamente l'over ma non ho
ben capito il senso Adidas
ragazzi
silenzio Oh my god con
1.200.000.000.00 ragazzi
però mamma mia è bello bello alto anche
lui
Oddio sarà un metro e Settanta No però
comunque 4 i film sono sempre 450
di più attenzione ragazzi
Guarda che Quando giocavo non facevo mai
sta roba Porca [ __ ] secondo me il
prossimo è meno Eh sì sicuramente è meno
il kayak con le sue 11.000 di ricerche
Porca [ __ ]
è l'inventore del kayama Esatto
ma che
cazzo fa sul Naviglio meno Star Trek
comunque è sempre tanto eh Un bel po' di
jeans Ecco questa è una gran battaglia
meno di meno però se la giocano Eh porca
[ __ ] raga 24 di fila Ma quanto era il
tuo ah ah alla maschera messa malissimo
non vede nulla e direi Lower è molto
lover
[Musica]
ragazzi veramente un punteggio
incredibile Io non giocavo da una vita
neanche tu mi sa bel libro veramente
Ragazzi infatti pochissimo super Happy
quindi ragazzi cambiamo giochino e siamo
su hater io che sarebbe preferibile eh
Un ritorno a Macedonia bello Mi è
piaciuta questa cosa Bravo bella idea
Dai andiamo avanti andiamo avanti allora
preferiresti combattere contro un
alligatore o combattere contro un orso
contro un orso perché ci sono molte
tecniche per evitare di per vincere
contro un orso Anche perché potrebbe
diventare Eh dai bro però poi è
alligatore No che cazzo sei pure in un
in un secondo me
ma penso tutti eh E invece io comunque
non capite niente mamma mia raga è
terribile l'alligatore preferite essere
me oppure essere me di fare sempre tardi
perché dopo un po' la gente secondo me
si abitua Sì esatto l'audio due secondi
prima del video Oh
preferirei Praticamente ehm il video di
2 secondi eh prima dell'audio Perché
almeno so l'audio prima del video Grazie
all'audio Prima del video che comunque è
molto è bruttissima come Forse è
veramente fastidiosa Vai eri assestato
qualcosa Ok Claudio Invece no La gente
non capisce un cazzo guardi contro
questa cosa qua perché in effetti per
esempio un jumpscare È vero Prima capito
inceppare costantemente quando si
cammina studia costantemente quando
parli
crea un tema di ingresso quando entri in
una stanza cioè quando tu entri parte la
musica di Darth Vader
la seconda che hai detto Però è
bellissimo che magari entri in chiesa
quindi è doppio doppio surround però eh
in chiesa e parte la musica qualcuno
bellissima voglio assolutamente entrare
sta roba Sì un nudista Sì un never nude
assolutamente nudista No col cazzo never
news
Sì ok questa la possiamo chiedere alla
tua mamma No beh ti risponderà prima
Certo che mi risponde da prima però
Vediamo Tentiamo di dissuaderla dalla
prima
della situazione che comunque è belzebú
Intanto è un concetto astratto
all'interno poi Dobbiamo stabilire
signora le cedo anche il posto sì no no
non sono io di casa quindi non mi voglio
appropriare di che dobbiamo fare qua ci
chiedono se preferiremmo vivere poveri
con Gesù Cristo e andare in paradiso o
vivere ricchi con Satana ma andare
all'inferno quale preferirebbe lei
signora
Scusate mio preferisco vivere dovrei
andare in paradiso Scusatemi non mi
mancherebbe
però ci sono delle considerazioni da
fare cioè ad esempio Satana è una
persona che punisce i cattivi Quindi da
un certo punto di vista cioè nel senso
fa le cose giuste
Ah bravo che hai fatto il cattivo tieni
con noi vieni qua Capito Allora io ho
sempre pensato io personalmente E Dio
che dice a Satana questo te lo devi
portare all'infanzia Giada na cosa fa il
cane in modo Fai in modo che le persone
diventino cattive per conquistarsi il
suo spazio
dice Sai che ti dico ho più popolazione
io nel mio inferno che tu nel tuo
paradiso quindi sono meglio di te sono
due grandi bambinoni allora
Gesù è stato tentato da Satana Satana lo
ha portato per il mondo vi ha fatto
vedere quello che gli avrebbe regalato
tutto quello che era possibile
immaginabili
non si è fatto diventare qui Questa è la
Reale
perché non sto sfottendo No no io non ho
nulla da aggiungere
si può essere ricchi però nella
ricchezza non bisogna mai dimenticarsi
di quelli che stanno peggio di noi
quindi questa ricchezza se voi Guardate
anche a chi non ne ha Penso che anche
chi è ricco può fin può andare in
paradiso non per forza deve solo andare
all'inferno
meraviglioso
quanta profondità inaspettata grazie No
grazie veramente cioè sono sono andato
io so che voi giovani siete ormai
lontani anni luce dal dal mondo dalla
religione
mio figlio poi in modo particolare
Perché cresciuta Quando gioca la God of
War Signore io sono cresciuto dalle
suore cioè Materna ed elementare nella
terza media è stata dalle suore per me è
un grande dolore
non abbia più voglia ma pure io
inizialmente ero così pure io sono
cresciuta con le suore però poi
giustamente ma ci sono state dei momenti
in cui mi sono resa conto che bisogna
credere in qualcosa di molto più grande
di noi Io mi sono riunita alle mie
vecchie la mia vecchia al mio vecchio
modo di guardare il mondo
Grazie bellissimo
farò tesoro di tanti consigli spero
anche Buongiorno e anche i ragazzi
insomma Grazie prego ci vediamo in un
prossimo episodio Scusatemi abbiamo
fatto un video un po' Easy oggi ma
perché post vacanze io anche io ci metto
una settimana a riprendermi eh
un prossimo episodio iscrivetevi al
canale e passate anche da pagina di
Giampiero lascio in descrizione
Instagram vlog e noi ci vediamo e mi
raccomando
Scegliete Gesù Sì beh ragazzi